choeur oui vous donneriez pas des
conseils jeunes mettant une belle
émission bernard parce que je trouve
qu'il ya des gens passionnants dont les
acteurs ces merveilleuses que d'isabelle
il ya des textes de jouvet sublime moi
je prépare un spectacle dans un an sur
un génie absolu qu'est jouvet on peut
pas la télévision
parler sérieusement des choses c'est ça
votre génie c'est que vous vous l'avez
toujours parlé avec de la jubilation
quelquefois réductrice mais la
télévision c'est pas un lieu sérieux
sauf quand il ya des identités
exceptionnels comme les gens qui sont là
donc on admire a donc on parle des gens
qui ont vraiment avec isabelle aussi
bien sûr que j'intègre mais moi je donne
ma place dans une espèce de démarche
totalement fraternelle mais bernard très
grande forme ce soir
non mais bonne humeur vous pourriez être
nostalgique pas du tout dynamique vivant
physique comme il est quoi
eh ben vous finissez par être assez bons
dans la vie il ya eu un seul le pivot il
est beau alors parlons gens passionnants
de la meilleure je suis très allants
présentation ne s'agit pas que sur la
barre acteurs justement un texte sur
quelques mots alors justement sur le
théâtre parce que je voulais c'est quand
même le théâtre puisque le cinéma bravi
quelques mots sur le théâtre de tous les
sens que j'ai dit sur la télévision et
bien sûr d'autant que l'a pas fait pour
être intéressante et passionnante du
tout contrairement à ce que disent les
gens c'est réducteur l'image toujours à
les hivernants je vais le faire parler
une parole de la télé c'est incroyable
comme s'ils allaient d'ailleurs donc